based on greg rucka and the ando
fernandez his image comic series the
movie adaptation of the old guard hit
Netflix in summer 2020 and we've got the
major differences between the two right
here fair warning to all you mortals
spoilers ahead for both the comic and
movie the old guard follows a heroine
named on drama key of Sofia
played by Charlize Theron this
apparently modern woman serves as the
leader of a lively team of mercenaries a
group which also includes characters by
the names of Booker Joe and Nikki these
are actually the modernized versions of
their names because like on drama key or
Andy for short they're all immortal and
impossibly old the comic features
numerous flashbacks to all their
fascinating origin stories and while
Andy gets a few flashbacks in the film
her associates largely just tell rather
than show their true natures the comic
goes into much more detail about who
they are and how they came to be so
audience members who only watch the
movie will miss out on dramatic
formative moments like the story of how
Booker fought with Napoleon's army in
the 1800s or how lovers Joe and Nikki
met when they were fighting on opposite
sides during the Crusades in the comics
Andy is the classic lone wolf action
hero with a dark and violent past lots
of secrets and a reluctance to let
anyone get past her emotional barriers
she also does whatever she can to make
herself feel alive if only for a little
while
the first issue opens with Andy walking
away from a one-night stand not even
wanting to know the guy's name on her
way out the door
readers also get a flashback to the time
she fell in love with a former slave
named Achilles which ended when he got
old and pushed her away in the film
version Andy's romantic life isn't
explored at all all her feelings seem to
be totally wrapped up in her devotion to
her de facto family of mercenaries the
Andy of the comics is more than just a
sardonic gun-for-hire growing tired of
death and rebirth she resents and
distrust the modern world believing that
people have grown worse over the
centuries she thinks technology provides
a means to make cruelty faster and more
efficient the movie version of Andy also
thinks that Humanity is on a downward
trajectory
but she doesn't seem to fear gadgets
early in the old guard comics Andy fails
to properly use a smartphone and resents
having to learn the interface on a new
iPad she's old but it's established
right away in the film version - the old
car that Andy has no problem using
electronic devices when she realizes
she's appeared in the background of a
stranger's photo while on a hotel
vishi offers to take another picture for
the stranger herself definitely and
quickly deleting the first pic in order
to preserve her secret identity
she's also apparently keenly aware of
how phones tracked people after she
makes a call she smashes the phone one
of the most memorable and entertaining
set pieces in the movie doesn't actually
appear in the comic after convincing
nyle who has just learned of her own
immortality to come with her to meet the
others and he loads her into a cargo
plane carrying a load of drugs nyle
wanders is such a transport too safe and
Andi Riley informs her that such things
don't really matter to immortals nyle
isn't convinced so she straps herself
into her seat and he casually holds the
ceiling of the cabin and takes a swig
from a bottle of vodka as the flight
progresses nyle attempts to take control
restraining Andi and attempted to hijack
the plane and he calls her blop and
shoots the pilot pilot we can jump in
survived
but as it turns out she only pretended
to shoot him she told him in Russian to
pretend to be dead a command that gets a
callback in the movies climax a lair is
necessary for a good superhero it's a
place to relax plan and most importantly
be as far away as possible from enemies
snoops and the general public so
obviously the old guard has won and the
differences between the comics and
movies headquarters also reflect the
differences between the comic and movie
versions of Andy's character the comics
old guard meeting a decrepit building
full of trash broken glass and used
needles not exactly homey in the film
Andy nyle and company have much nicer
digs reflecting their more familial
relationship a well preserved abandoned
church and a French forest the only
downside it's near an airport so flying
planes are a little loud movies often
need a character to serve as an audience
surrogate who can ask a lot of questions
and get a lot of answers in the form of
exposition ex-marine turned ageless
immortal warrior Niall doesn't play this
role in the comic but in the movie she
does she's arguably the movies lead
character serving as a grounded
counterpoint to the more experienced
characters and their unreal world on
behalf of the audience in the book Niles
military career isn't given much thought
before Andy whisks her away in the film
you received his trust she generates and
how she comes to terms with both her
role on the team and her newly
discovered immortality her backstory is
explored in more detail as well most
notably Niall becomes the hero of the
movie rescuing everyone in the comics
Joe and Nikki just bust themselves out
of Marik's lab in the movie before she
found her current squad of immortals and
he met another immortal named Quinn a
flashback sequence depicts them fighting
alongside one another and developing a
profound friendship just you and me
until the end they're eventually
captured and accused of witchcraft upon
surviving the deadly trial they're
deemed too powerful to be allowed to
stay together and he looks on helplessly
his authorities dragged went away
confine her to a metal coffin and throw
her into the ocean where she spent the
last few centuries drowning dying and
coming back to life
Andy reveals that she spent a long time
looking for Gwen but has never found her
Gwen is the reason Andy protects her
teammates so ceaselessly Gwen's fate
ends up serving as an inspiration for
the entire old guard but only in the
movie surprisingly she's not a curator
in the comic at all check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite action
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]